let's do one more in the name of giving
in the name of Christmas and the name of
our lineage and our friends our family
and our community and our world amen
Cheers to your brother to you oh yeah
hello I'm Phil Henry and today we'll be
discussing the man who created modern
Christmas Charles Dickens holy yeah
man
Thank You Phil let's go for it thanks
brother so Charles Dickens has smash-hit
in England he's a very very prominent
writer and he's sitting there thinking I
don't know I've I've written Nicholas
Nickleby the Old Curiosity Shop the
thing called Oliver Twist now he wanted
to speak about the you know the
degenerating aspects of English society
English society is a big hovel it's a
steaming mass of justice and you've got
poverty and the end the end the the the
ragged schools and the people are like
that's really great man you got another
Oliver Twist I really appreciate it
because man you are boring mate suddenly
everybody's leaving so now his
publishers don't want to publish him the
people are not all that interested in
his political points of view because
he's a long-winded dull creep and
suddenly in 1843 out of the blue comes
an invitation I think that you unban to
the Athenian of Manchester coming
anything except inception sound so full
huh so he goes up there he sees the big
sign the Atheneum of Manchester if it's
actually a place where the working class
in the poor could go to hear educated
people speak so he gives his speech and
he looks at across this vast sea of pace
of the paces oh man whoo holy
and it is then that it hits him
you are the regular people the working
people the people of England but the man
that I see is overseeing all of these
people that I'm looking at tonight he's
an asshole is that's the word yes I'm
looking with the word asshole and that
night he went out and he walked they
began to think about this tale by God
I saw in the face of those people I saw
the very working man I saw the man that
I was and the boy that I was those are
the faces all the suffering people that
I've been working with yeah you're my
people aren't you yes sir in his mind
he's doing this it's not really
happening oh so it began to coalesce in
his mind he goes back to London and he's
beginning to put this together in his
mind with the time of year well this is
the birth of Christ doesn't this is
Christmas he's thinking about love and
charity and and how all that's missing
in this world that he'd been living in
and Dickens suddenly got the idea for a
tale of the working class coming in
touch with this redemptive spirit of
Christmas and he says I saw the man that
was keeping them down evany sir Scrooge
and his sister had a little boy who had
what was called tuberculosis of the bone
Tiny Tim he's thinking about this tale
of these three ghosts that was the
Christmas spirit of whatever that
happened before the Christmas spirit of
the future the Christmas spirit of now
and he keeps writing and he keeps
writing and he keeps writing until his
hand gets tired and he looks and he sees
a Christmas Carol Charles Dickens writes
a Christmas carol in six weeks right
away gone yeah Wow Chuck Dickens Charles
if you will I will went to his publisher
and the publisher said Chuck you haven't
had a hit baby in years man I'm not
gonna publish this so he leaves he goes
home and he's thinking this is
impossible man all these guys are
telling me the same thing that I stink
on ice
bull I was self-published yeah that's
right
he has John leach who was a very
well-known illustrator do the
illustrations but who hadn't bind his
stuff up
I can put in a multicolored paper I can
give it a little kind of a flash even a
little bit a little cell they'd print
6,000 copies bang sells out it was a hit
a Christmas carol is virtually
internationally renowned his fortunes
take off again and he begins to perform
a Christmas carol while a German mr.
Charles Dickens thank you thank you let
me get my glasses but here we go a
Christmas carol you mind anyone all
right here we go one two and one two
three a Christmas Carol one night it's
all duck excuse my language and begin a
Christmas Carol
I'm Charles Dickens suddenly the ghost
of Christmas present becomes the ghost
of Christmas past and tidy and Tiny Tim
came bouncing down the lane and he said
father I'm crippled and Bob Cratchit
said no what else is new are we
still doing the show anyway with the
publishing of that book he reinvigorated
the whole idea of Christmas as a time of
gift-giving and a time of embrace a time
of warmth the time of sharing by the way
Christmas Carol was released on December
the 19th 1843 that's a hundred and
seventy four years to the day tonight
shares the Charles Dickens Judy man to
Yen
you
[Music]